un camion de produits pharmaceutiques a
été braquée hier soir alors qu'ils
allaient à oklahoma je vais vous
demander d'ouvrir votre camion
on sait très bien ce que cherche à ceux
qui ont fait le coup
reste cool reste co
je voudrais juste savoir pourquoi tu
fais parce que c'est dans notre sens
comment ça s'est passé
d'accord c'est ce que j'avais entendu
j'aurais les anniversaires boni merci à
toi pas d'autres je connais bien compris
aïda walker a pris 25 ans pour homicide
involontaire et complicité de larmes
sont nombreuses mais systématiquement
sur toutes les affaires importantes
n'importe quoi un train de tout ce
merdier elle sait avec qui elle s'est
mariée à mon avis ils les ont enfin
compris la portée de son pouvoir elle
veut qu'on fasse le ménage tu manques et
avec qui
qui vous envoie [ __ ] haidar aide
suivez moi
combien rapporte est à faire
les millions
tous les mois quelques maniaques du
pétrole atterrissent en provenance du
middle east il ramène du cash de
contrats dont ils ne parlent pas
interdit coup qu'on arrête c'est fini
je connais ce regard c'est quand tu m'as
ni danse un truc je suis ce que tu es
devenue la côte elle
prépare toi
[Musique]
royal